I've talked a lot about the idea that
eigenvectors could make for good basis
or good basis vectors so let's explore
that idea a little bit more let's say I
have some transformation let's say to
transformation from RN to RN and it can
be represented by the matrix a so the
transformation of X is equal to the N by
n matrix a to n by n times X now let's
say let's say that we have n linearly
independent eigen vectors of a so let's
say and this isn't always going to be
the case but it can often be the case
you know it's definitely possible let's
say let's assume let's assume that a has
n linearly independent eigen vectors
eigen vector so I'm going to call them V
1 V 2 all the way through V n now and
linearly independent vectors in RN will
definitely can definitely be a basis for
RN we've seen that multiple times and
what I want to show you in this video is
that this makes a particularly good
basis for this transformation so let's
explore that so the transformation of
each of these vectors now write it over
here the transformation of vector one is
equal to a times vector one and since
vector one is an eigenvector of a that's
going to be equal to some Augen value
lambda 1 times vector 1 we could do that
for all of them the transformation of
vector 2 is equal to a times V 2 which
is equal to some I in value lambda 2
times V 2 and I'm just going to skip all
of them and just go straight to the nth
one is we have n of these eigenvectors
you might have a lot more we're just
assuming that a has at least n linearly
independent eigenvectors in general you
could take scaled up versions of these
and they'll also be eigenvectors let's
see so the
of VN is going to be equal to a times VN
and because these are all eigenvectors a
a times VN is just going to be lambda
and some eigenvalue times the vector V n
now what are these also equal to well
this is equal to and this is probably
going to be unbelievably obvious to you
but this is the same thing as lambda 1
times v1 plus 0 times v2 plus all the
way to 0 times VN and this right here is
going to be it's going to be 0 times v1
plus lambda 2 times v2 plus all the way
0 times all of the other vectors VN and
then this guy down here this is going to
be 0 times v1 plus 0 times v2 plus 0
times all of these basis vectors these
eigen vectors but lambda n times VN I
mean this is almost stunningly obvious
right I just rewrote this as this plus a
bunch of 0 vectors but the reason why I
wrote that is in the second we're going
to find we're going to take this as a
basis so we're going to find coordinates
with respect to that basis and so this
guy's coordinates will be or your lambda
1 0 0 because that's the coefficients on
our basis vectors so let's do that so
let's say that we have we define this as
some basis so B is equal to the set of
actually I'm going to write it that way
let's say I say that B I have some basis
B that's equal to that what I want to
show you is that when I do a change of
basis so when I do a change of basis so
we've seen this before in my standard
coordinates or in coordinates with
respect to the standard basis you give
me some vector in RN I'm going to
multiply it times a and you're going to
how the transformation of it so it's
going to be an RN now we know we can do
a change of basis we know we could do a
change of basis and in a change of basis
if you want to go in that way you
multiply by C inverse which is and
remember the change of basis matrix C if
you want to go in this direction you
multiply by C the change of basis matrix
is just a matrix with all of these
vectors as columns if it's very easy to
but if you change your basis from X to
our new basis you multiply by the
inverse of that we've seen that multiple
times if they're all orthonormal then
this is the same thing as a transpose we
can't assume that though and so this is
going to be X in our new basis and if we
want to find some transformation if we
want to find the transformation matrix
for T with respect to our new basis it's
going to be some some matrix D and if
you multiply D times X you're going to
get this guy but you're going to get the
B representation of that guy the
transformation of the vector X is B
representation and if we want to go back
and forth between that guy and that guy
if we want to go in this direction you
can multiply this times C and you'll
just get the transformation of X and if
you want to go in that direction you
could multiply by the inverse of your
change of basis matrix we've seen this
multiple times already but what I've
claimed or I've kind of hinted at is
that if I have a basis that's defined by
eigenvectors of a that this will be a
very nice matrix so this lack be the
debate this might be the coordinate
system that you want to operate in
especially if you're going to apply this
matrix a lot if you're going to do this
transformation on a lot of different
things you're going to do it over and
over and over again maybe to the same
set then it maybe is worth the overhead
to do the conversion and just use this
as your as your coordinate system so
let's let's see that this is actually
this that this will actually be a
nice-looking easy to compute with an
actually diagonal matrix so we know that
the transformation what is the
transformation of let's write this in a
bunch of different formats let me scroll
down a little bit so if I wanted to
write the transformation of v1 and B
coordinates what would it be it's just
going to be equal to well these are the
basis vectors right so it's the
coefficient on the basis vector so it's
going to be it's going to be equal to
lambda1 and then it's a bunch of zeros
it's lambda one times v1 plus 0 times v2
plus 0 times v3 all the way to 0 times
the N that's what it's equal to but it's
also equal to
to D and we can write D like this D is
also transformation between RN and RN
just a different coordinate system so D
is going to just be a bunch of column
vectors D 1 D 2 all the way through D n
times this is the same thing as D times
our B representation of the vector v1
but what is our B representation of the
vector v1
well the vector v1 is just 1 times v1
plus 0 times v2 plus 0 times v3 all the
way to all the way to V all the way to 0
times VN v 1 is a basis vector so it's
just 1 times itself plus 0 times
everything else so that's this is what
its representation is in the B
coordinate system now what is this going
to be equal to and we've seen this
before this is a little bit of review
I might even be boring you this is just
equal to 1 times d1 plus 0 times d2
plus 0 times all the other columns so
this is just equal to d1 so we dislike
that we have our first column of our
matrix D we could just keep doing that
now I'll do it multiple times the
transformation the transformation of v2
in our new coordinate system orthrus
pecked to our new basis is going to be
equal to well we know what the
transformation of v2 is it's 0 times v1
0 times v1 plus lambda 2 times v2 lambda
2 times V 2 and then plus 0 times
everything else 0 times everything else
and that's the same thing as d d1 d2 all
the way through DN times our B
representation of vector - well vector 2
is one of the basis vectors it's just 0
times v1 plus 1 times v2 plus 0 times v3
all the way the rest is 0 so what's this
going to be equal to this is 0 times d2
sorry 0 times d1 plus 1 times D 2 and 0
times everything else it's equal to d2 I
think you get the general idea I'll do
it one more time as to really hammer the
point home the transformation of the
10th basis vector which is also an eigen
that I can vector of our original matrix
a or of our transformation in standard
coordinates in B coordinates is going to
be equal to what
well we wrote it right up here it's
going to be a bunch of zeroes it's 0
times all of these guys plus lambda n
times VN and this is going to be this
guy D 1 D 2 all the way to DN times the
B representation of the of the nth basis
vector which is just 0 times V 1 0 times
V 2 and 0 times all of them except for 1
times V N and so this is going to be
equal 0 times D 2 plus 0 times 0 times D
1 plus 0 times D 2 plus 0 times all of
these guys all the way to 1 times D n
that's going to be equal to DN and just
like that
we have we know what are what are our
transformation matrix is going to look
like with respect to this new basis
where this basis was defined or it's
made up of a but of n linearly
independent eigenvectors of our original
matrix a so what does d look like d our
matrix D is going to look like its first
column is right there it's we figure
that one out lambda 1 and then we just
have a bunch of zeros its second column
is right here D 2 is equal to this so
it's 0 lambda 2 and then a bunch of
zeros and then this is in general the
case the nth column is going to have a 0
everywhere except along the diagonal is
going to be lambda n it's going to be
the eigen value for the nth eigen vector
and so the diagonal is going to look and
you're going to have lambda 3 all the
way down to lambda N and our nth column
is lambda n with just a bunch of zeros
everywhere so D when we picked this is a
neat result when you if if a has n
linearly independent eigen vectors and
this isn't always the case but you can
figure out the eigen vectors and say hey
I can take a collection of n of these
that are linearly independent then those
will be a basis for RN and linearly
independent vectors in RN are a basis
4rn and but when you put when you use
that basis when you use the I give you
linearly independent eigenvectors of a
as a basis we call this an eigenbasis
eigen eigen basis the transformation
matrix with respect to that eigenbasis
it becomes a very very nice matrix this
is super easy to multiply it's super
easy to invert it's super easy to take
the determinant of we've seen it
multiple times it just has a ton of neat
properties it's just a good basis to be
dealing with so that's one of you know
that's kind of the big takeaway you know
in all of linear algebra we did all the
stuff with spaces and vectors and all of
that but in general vectors are abstract
representations of real world I guess
you know real world things you could
represent a vectors you know the stock
returns or you could be a vector of you
know whether in a certain part of the
country and you can create these spaces
based on the number of dimensions and
all of that and then you're gonna have
transformations you know sometimes when
you do about Markov chains your
transformations are essentially you know
what's the probability of you know after
one time increment that's something you
know something state will change to
something else and then you'll want to
apply that matrix many many many many
times to see what you know kind of what
the stable state is for a lot of things
I know I've I'm not explaining any of
this to you well but I wanted to tell
you that all of linear algebra is really
just a very general way to solve a whole
universe of problems and what's useful
about this is you can have
transformation matrices that define
these functions essentially on data sets
and what we've learned now is that when
you look at the eigenvectors and the
eigenvalues you can change your basis so
that you can solve your problems in much
simpler ways and it's all very abstract
right now and but you now have the
toolkit and you know the rest of your
life you kind of have to figure out how
to apply this toolkit to specific
problems in probability or statistics or
finance or you know or modeling weather
systems or who knows what else